horror fans have had a lot to scream
about these past few years and it looks
like we're going to have even more
scares ahead of us from remakes of
terrifying Classics and chilling sequels
to the ghostly promise of brand new IP
here's gamespot's list of the 25 best
horror games to look forward to in 2023
and Beyond
Dead Space remake after the divisive
reception of dead space's spiritual
successor the Callisto protocol all eyes
have now turned to the remake of the
original game by EA's motive Studio the
Remake will again follow the Journey of
engineer Isaac Clarke as he fights off
hordes of grotesque alien creatures on a
derelict spaceship along with a sharp
graphical makeover the Remake will bring
new improvements like a propulsion boost
and the ability to move in all 360
Degrees while spacewalking so you're
gonna have even more angles to dismember
monsters from which hopefully uh will
make it less scary
redfall Arcane the studio behind
Dishonored and prey is trying its hand
at an XBox exclusive four-player Co-op
FPS a la Left 4 Dead this time however
the twist is that you're in a world
filled with super-powered vampires while
the formula may be tried and true Arcane
will hopefully bring its unique
immersive Sim style of gameplay to the
genre in order to make it feel fresh and
if that doesn't make it fresh then
hopefully your blood will make it fresh
to the vampires
foreign
Unholy is a first-person shooter and
Atmospheric psychological horror that
has you explore two parallel Dimensions
as you search for your child one a
mysterious Eastern European town and two
a twisted world ruled by a Relentless
priesthood the game will also feature a
combat system that has you use emotions
to interact with the environment and
damage your opponents it's an ambitious
Twist on the genre that could prove to
be unique as well as get you emotional
Alan Wake 2 remedy is ready to bring us
back to the messed up world of Stephen
king-esque novelist Alan Wake in the
long-awaited sequel to the psychological
third person horror game remedy's last
game control featured a crossover with
Alan Wake in its DLC creating a
connection between the two worlds that
many of us fans were excited to explore
further plus we'll get a chance to
explore the tortured inner workings of
Alan Wake himself
System Shock System Shock was a major
inspiration for numerous games in the
genre including later hits like Bioshock
and after a successful Kickstarter
campaign night dive Studios is ready to
bring it back with what originally began
as a remaster that has now morphed into
a full on reboot sadly night dive has
run into development troubles related to
the pandemic and other factors but the
game is set to be coming in 2023 and we
are excited to see what they come up
with
Amnesia the bunker the horror game
series that may not have created but
certainly how popularized the
disempowered unable to fight back
against the monster's genre of horror
for a generation of YouTube creators and
Watchers is back with a new first person
horror game set in a World War One
bunker like the rest of the games in the
series The Bunker looks to be a tense
experience as you work to find a way out
while trying to escape threats the game
also features a semi-open world
randomized elements a new crafting
system and even the ability to defend
yourself this time I'm sure it'll be a
ton of help and I won't spend half my
time running around screaming like
little babies
foreign
the follow-up to the critically
acclaimed oxenfree is coming this year
and this time you play as Riley who
returns to her hometown to investigate a
mysterious radio signal but finds that
there may be more going on than meets
the eye while it's not I perfectly snug
fit in the horror genre oxen free 2
certainly brings with it an eerie
atmosphere that is definitely unsettling
at the very least it's going to continue
the original game's excellent story
aliens Dark Descent time once again to
face the Xenomorphs in this single
player real-time strategy game set
within the alien franchise the game
seems very x-coming at first glance but
unlike that turn-based series all the
action here takes place in real time
forcing you to react on the Fly while
still having to keep your larger
strategy in mind you'll be exploring a
base so you can use the terrain to force
Xenomorphs into closed off sections but
at the cost of shutting yourself off
from those sections as well it's
definitely a unique take on both the
genre and franchise that we hope doesn't
lead us to be game over man game over
game over man this game over sorry I
apologize
layers of fear blooper team is returning
to the franchise that built their
reputation in the horror genre this time
teaming up with anshar Studios layers of
fear seems to feature all the Hallmarks
of the first person horror franchise
this time focusing on a single character
rather than several Generations Looper
team also promises a subtle yet new
approach to the series
the last case of Benedict Fox the last
case of Benedict Fox is a 2.5 D
narrative action adventure that dives
into the world of murders rituals and
secret organizations sounds like a lot
of fun if you're a fan of metroidvania
style Platformers but want one with more
of a Gothic horror flavor then this game
should definitely be on your radar
sons of the forest the sequel to The
Cult hit the forest sons of the forest
is a survival horror game that promises
to continue the nail-biting gameplay of
the first you'll scavenge for items as
you try to survive the creepy challenges
and strange inhabitants of the forest
while also starting to uncover the
mystery of what lies at the heart of the
horror around you
Resident Evil 4 remake the original
Resident Evil 4 was a medium-defining
piece of work that influenced all that
came after it so marrying it with the
hugely successful style of the recent
re2 and re3 remix has us pumped that
this remake might continue resident
Evil's domination as one of Gaming's
best horror franchises one of the best
games of all time being married with the
gameplay of some of the best remakes of
all time need we say more just hopefully
they fix those damn escort missions
routine we revealed last year routine is
a first person sci-fi horror game set in
a 1980s vision of the future it takes
place on a lunar base but after the base
goes quiet you must go face to face with
an enemy who sees you as the real threat
you'll need to explore the capitalist
dystopia of your sci-fi surroundings and
stay alive and figure out what's worse
capitalism or Monsters like I said it's
very 1980s
The Texas Chainsaw Massacre Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is returning to gaming
in the same vein as other horror
franchises like evil dead and Friday the
13th have done before it with an
asymmetrical multiplayer game however
this game promises to bring a new twist
to the genre with it not being four on
one but four on three with three players
playing as the murderous attackers it's
definitely an interesting variation upon
the genre and one which we're curious to
see if it pays off if not at least
you'll get a unique tasting meal to chew
on
killer clowns from outer space yet if
that asymmetrical horror game isn't to
your taste then we've got another one
coming that just might be this one is
going to be based on the 80s classic
killer clowns from outer space and will
also bring the same twist to the genre
by changing up the numbers this time
with it being three versus seven players
with the clowns attempting to capture
all the human citizens that they can
while the humans try to destroy the
Clown's spaceship it should provide a
grim laugh
the Outlast trials like Amnesia another
popular series in the de-powered horror
genre is making its triumphant return
with the Outlast trials third
installment and prequel to The Outlast
series will find you as one of four test
subjects who must work together to
escape a cold war experiment in this
Co-op experience hopefully that means
that you don't all die together this
time
Silent Hill 2 remake it's been a long
time since Silent Hill fans have had
anything to get excited about given that
kojima's PT failed to materialize into
an actual game due to let's just say
numerous factors but now it seems that
Konami is trying to finally make good on
the franchise's Promise by handing
layers of fear creators blooper team the
Reigns to a remake of the franchise's
most iconic title once again you'll play
as James Sunderland who travels to the
strange town of Silent Hill after
receiving a letter from his dead wife
and soon finds himself facing [ __ ]
that dive deep into his psyche
Silent Hill Town fall there's not just a
remake coming for Silent Hill fans
though but a brand new game too not much
is known about town fall Beyond its name
but Konami promises that the game will
shake things up for the horror franchise
and that it's being developed by no code
the studio that made observation so
we're excited to see what this team
comes up with
[Music]
slitter head the Creator behind Silent
Hill and Gravity Rush is working to
create a new horror experience with
slitterhead the game is said to feature
grotesque insect monsters and that's
about all we know so we'll be keeping
our eyes all dozens of them on this game
Fort Solis another sci-fi horror game
this time in third person instead on
Mars for its solo sees you play as Jack
Leary an engineer sent to respond to a
routine alarm on a Mining facility and
we're totally sure that'll be a very
normal house call completely routine
nothing strange about it not much else
is known about the game except that
studio Fallen Leaf promises an immersive
narrative along the lines of Studio
games from supermassive games or Quantic
dream and that this game is going to
Star Troy Baker and Red Dead Redemption
2's Roger Clark so it certainly got the
talent behind it
the dark pictures Anthology directive
8020 speaking of supermassive games
though the next game in their dark
pictures Anthology is also a sci-fi
horror directive 8020 is the fifth entry
in the uneven yet generally well
received franchise and the first in the
series second season this one is set on
the space vessel Cassiopeia but beyond
that supermassive has remained mostly
tight-lipped on the details knowing them
though it should be a narrative heavy
game filled with tough choices and
terrifying moments
[Music]
stalker 2 heart of Chernobyl despite
having been delayed due to the invasion
of Ukraine by Russia stalker 2 still
plans to be an ambitious step forward
for the series much like the other
entries in the franchise stalker 2 takes
place in the nuclear exclusion zone or
the Zone in a radiated Chernobyl but
Supernatural elements lurk about to
create a horror-like atmosphere it's
said that stalker 2 is going to have one
of the biggest open worlds in gaming
which sounds pretty daunting for the
first person action franchise but we're
certainly ready to see what we can find
and explore
alone in the dark our penultimate game
is yet another remake but one that is
the most radical in its Recreation a
self-described love letter to the 90s
cult classic alone in the dark aims to
completely reimagine the 30 year old
game that helped to popularize the fixed
camera horror games like the original
Resident Evil series set in a unique
manner alone in the dark promises to
revitalize and overlooked yet seminal
franchise in the horror gaming world
Dead Island 2. despite seeming to have
died years ago Dead Island 2 was finally
reanimated in 2022 leaving us excited
that the series still can take a bite
out of its competition Dying Light damn
Buster Studios seems to be well aware of
the expectations it has on its shoulders
and looks to bring in exciting open
world Los Angeles and San Francisco to
its new combat mechanics and rage
systems like unique zombie Powers so
we're excited to take a bite out of this
one and see if it lives up or if it's
just going to die once again
and those are our picks for the top 25
horror games coming out in 2023 and
Beyond but there are certainly a ton
more to get terrified about so let us
know what you're dreading in the
comments below and don't forget to
subscribe to Gamespot for coverage on
many of these and more games in 2023